can
イボの自動今朝の4時39ですこんばんわはじめ社長です
いつもポケ峰号の動画はサブチャンネルに出すんですけどもテンションがあったとき
だけ便利を出します肇社長です皆さん
まだポケモンゴーやってますか
か不明花粉がやばいなんか知ってる人は知ってますよね今ポケモンゴーで
new が出現していますでね今まで行った伝説のポケモンっとかっていうのはその
レイドバトルって言って
例えばルギアとかで強い敵をみんなでよってかかって僕にするっていうのがまあデート
バトルだったんですけどミューズはちょっと違いまして今までの
日本語になかったシステムで手に入るようになってたんですよあとこのポケモンは待っ
てこれ原田各社を義母に新しいシステムみたいなの導入されちまって
まあそれでどんなのかといいますとポケモンリサーチっていう面ではこの博士がいるん
ですよ
そのおじさん
うわぁありがとうおかげで集作品が課税者よ
ar カメラボードに隠れている web すると健全できる機能付それからこれで
みんな姿を見ることができるだろう
みうお得誘い出すことが出来れば大切なのは真っ直ぐな心と
みゅに会いたいという気持ちを強く持つことはこれけっこう広範なんですけど僕ほど
博士からもう無理難題
もう無理なったよホラヤ
やる奴といろんなミッションを課せられてそれを全部クリアしたものだけが
ビューに会う権利がもらえるというシステムでございます
5日間をグッズががをビクンと文管がの3日神楽全力で
アースすることありましていろいろすることだしなきゃいけない事とかでお仕事とか
色々子だしてくるなんか頑張って時間を見つけてやんでぇ
命じる
ここでクーポン
なぜできつかったんですよもうミュート見えつつ構えたら僕はもう
初期のポケモンは全部捕まえのことになるんですよそんな僕を待ってられないからね何
としてでも捕まえたら一瞬で僕はも見えのミッション1はいクリアするしかないと思っ
てつかめる寸前までいっていきましょうとあと2匹です後胴ベルトセレビィで終わりで
ございます私ちょっとホウエン地方じゃねあのキモリとか
アチャモとかの世代はまだちょっとやり切るじゃなくて110匹ぐらいしかんがいない
んですけどなぜミュウはもう目の前まで来たんですけど3日買うスムーズだけだして
本当にもこの墓ての言ってくるミッション
はぁっみたいなばっかりでめっちゃ大変でしたどんなだったっけな
とりあえずなったレイドバトル2回やるとかこう言われてレーダーわたりやレーダーは
狂ってねその日中しかやってないんですよな門がやってないからちょっと出たがないん
ですけど花粉の中頑張って僕は
メイド待ってるしに行って行ったりメタも捕まえるとかよりましたね意外ないっていう
ステがばためたおっ
捕まえたですて後なんだゴーッとタイプつっ匹捕まえると
いるわけねーだろで切れ長ないよなんかね t 徘徊しながらボスタイプの僕の捕まえ
たりしてて
ほんとで結婚チックなのが多かったかなとこ inging 進化させるって言われて
コインがダメのは400個集めると言われてもうざけんじゃねって言いながら頑張って
コイキング捕まえに行きましたよ
今日の夜中ねさっきま
ねポケモンを捕まえるときに木南50個使うば画廊
かやっポンって博士うーん江戸三大デー
ドイツばがまあ的な実は49号で使ったんであと1回ポケモンに掴めるに衣を着ること
にポケモンを捕まえるときに1回機能を使えたら
ビューが出てくるみたいでございますじゃあ多分でわりと早いほうだと思います
なかなかすぐ手に入るようなものではないと思いますレイドバトル10回やるとかも
言われたし
1黒23日間の命を燃やしながら言うために頑張っ
にはスタンパーズしてはいラスト1匹でございます
こいつにえっなのにわかっててはいはいあきたきたきたきたきたきたきた
さあいきますよこの羽田に多分ミュウがいるんですよ
ボルヴィックがをかけるか持ったんだ絶対手に入れてやつかちゃうなぁ
[音楽]
ar モードを使う必要があります ar ではと叶う
や汚いけどいっかいきます
ポッパーバッグ
うまっ待って勃起れた芸たけど晴れ
これと言った
まってこれさあこの子でをレビュー談を
すごい new だー
湯がところに立ってるって透明になるんだねー
[音楽]
英断か ar じゃないとてる当面っていうのはかわいい
逃げないのかな不安だけどちょっと way 店主はこれな
マッキーロバーツと分かりやすいかなぁ
いるのわかりますね県透明なのね投げてみますとりあえず1回
ほいっ
ng
ar 1使わないかなぁ
ぽい
をどうぞ
やばい側ないこれまでおでこや動きをしてもレッスンなれるぞ
んっぽい
をぞ
[音楽]
とっていくん
わかんないんだか逃げないって言われてるらしいんですけど僕は信じていませんからね
あれどこ行ってどこ行った
ホイッ
多分
亀頭
うちゃー
3打つ構えだうんっううっっ
大間地玉子だ
4つくしょつく所
ゲイ見えだよみうはいと夕食で感動柄が150ページになりました所バックはあと1匹
3つだけですねちょっともうね薄着で疲れて何言いたいかわからなかったんですけど
本当だみたいで久しぶりに始まったねポケモンゴーで多いキングの寺崎でどんだけ池針
走り回ったことがほんとつらかったんですけど僕はもう
ポケモン
が好きなんであとエヴァそんな変な図鑑揃えたい
よく変なやっぱそういう性癖がの彼らを連れてポケモン図鑑がここまで来たんでここ
まできたなっていうとまで行ってみようって思っててなんかもう多少無理してでも僕は
ポケモンずかんそベル麻痺ありますよねーやんねます
ねはい時で見えちょっといつまでやってるかわかんないんですけども割と大変なんで
たぶんアメリカ鳩がいいのではないでしょうかちょっと者ジェリーテンションがベチャ
下がってしまってメインに出してしまいましたがポケモンゴーの動画サムネたまにだし
てるんで良かったらそちらもご覧くださいます度な
それぞれは長いデフレにつけようじゃんっ
me
ni
あっはぁ